[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to the dev zone
so my name is Jason Scott and I'm
excited to bring to you the next
presentation around leveraging cloud
data in ml for social good I currently
am a global program manager for our
startup program here at Google cloud and
I have two special guests that are gonna
talk about how they're leveraging Google
cloud for social impactful work but
first I'd like to rewind about twelve
months actually ten months to win sundar
announced our AI principles for those of
you who may not remember I'll quickly go
over what they were
so our first six principles were be
socially beneficial avoid creating or
reinforcing unfair bias be built and
taste tested for safety be accountable
to people incorporate privacy design
principles and six uphold high standards
of scientific excellence
however today I'd like to focus on
number seven so number seven was be made
available for uses at accord with these
principles so today I'm gonna bring up
two of our examples startups companies
that will talk about how they've
leveraged Google cloud to like I said
make social impactful solutions for the
world first up I have planet hello
everyone it's been great hearing all the
tremendous announcements around AI and
new checked in Google cloud platform
over the course of the last couple of
days and this week and next and I'm
excited to be telling you a little bit
about what planet's doing in the context
of social good so I'm go Kyle I head up
analytics engineering at Planet planets
integrated aerospace and data analytics
company founded with the mission of
imaging the entire world every day and
making daily change visible accessible
and actionable planet operates the
largest constellation of earth
observation satellites in human history
and
here's a quick run-through of how our
satellites operate the upwards of 130
satellites operating in a
sun-synchronous polar orbit that image
the earth like a line scanner our
flagship del constellation allows for
broad area always-on monitoring and we
complement that with a medium resolution
constellation called the Zeiss sky set
constellation that allows for higher
resolution monitoring in broad area
monitoring you're able to cover large
tracts of land and be able to have
precise insights derived from imagery
over the course of time so a little bit
more about the DAO constellations we
image at approximately three point nine
metres ground sampling distance we have
four bands of imagery and it through the
launches over the last several years we
now cover the entirety of the Earth's
landmass every day this allows for us to
be able to image and process and serve
imagery to our customers so we have
product offerings to our API that allow
for access to raw and processed scenes
as well as a collection of monthly and
seasonal mosaics that are available to
our customers the availability of our
imagery has enabled customers in many
different verticals to provide
transformative new capabilities that can
serve verticals like precision
agriculture government applications and
we believe that our forward-looking
vision is at the intersection of space
and artificial intelligence very
relevant to this current conference so
over the last several years our
customers have been able to extract a
variety of features from our imagery
this includes moving objects through
object detection
land use classification to semantic
segmentation and land kabbala mapping
using a combination of texture analysis
and semantic segmentation however those
are a few of the applications that are
commercially oriented the imagery that
we produce from our satellite
constellations have the potential for
widespread humanitarian impact disasters
natural disasters impact large tracts of
population they have the ability to
affect broad aspects of our social
fabric over a very quick time period
I wanted to walk through an example of
cyclone area assessment so many of you
know about cyclone EDI that impacted the
east coast of Africa in March it had
tremendous impact there were large areas
in the country of Mozambique and he was
just an example of like that like the
regions which it did affect zooming in a
little bit more closely this is an area
in the Donder district in Mozambique
that had widespread devastation so
looking at our monthly mosaics in this
area this is kind of what it looks like
in January now the the impact of having
daily imagery and monitoring already to
satellite Earth Observation is that you
are able to extract real-time
information or close to real-time
information of the disaster affected
areas not just before but also look at
the catalogue in history of what the
area looked like it also to identify
spots like this with tremendous amount
of human activity and human settlement
this allows disaster relief efforts to
be acute with high position maps of
human activity and it helps channel
relief efforts in the right direction in
specific locations however public
mapping information is often incomplete
so in that particular tile of mosaic
imagery this is the existing mock-up of
roads from a public data set like Open
Street Map however when we run semantic
segmentation on our imagery from a month
before the cyclone hit you're able to
see a lot more roads detected this is a
differential signal of the additional
roads that are detected through our
imagery and it allows for us to combine
these two sources public as well as data
derived from planet's imagery towards
creating signals that can help
responders at the time of need so I
wanted to walk through a slightly more
interactive example so this is the
imagery in that particular region of
Mozambique and here's an example of Road
detections what you see in red are
pixels classified as roads through
semantic segmentation and we can also
identify other artifacts of human
settlement like buildings so this is an
indicator of building footprints in that
region and you could serve this up at
larger scale over multiple districts and
this is real-time information that can
be used in disaster activities switching
back
I want to talk a little bit about ocean
monitoring so typhoons and tsunamis
often originate in the oceans and they
have widespread impact on land regions
as well as marine life
however monitoring oceans over large
scale is like relatively complex of a
problem and as we nest addressed in the
past so I walk through an example of
that before we look at oceans are one of
the first look at boats here's an
imagery of the Port of Oakland taken
from our satellites yesterday and when
we run an object detector you're able to
clearly identify boat activity like
ships in boats that provide an a
real-time nee signal unlike the kind of
aggregate activity in a region so
switching into a more interactive
exploration so this is that same region
over Oakland for an aggregate activity
over the entire year so we looked at
object detection over like the entire
every day over the course of this year
and this loaded it up loaded up the
detections and Kepler GL and open-source
package and you can see real-time
activity over the port over the course
of time each of these have been doing
over a couple of days which showcase the
kind of activity allowing for real-time
environmental monitoring in the same way
if he pointed to open ocean here's an
example this is in the South China Sea
closer to the Indian Ocean which is the
origin of many many tsunamis over the
last several years it allows you to
understand real-time patterns of life as
well as activity in the marine regions
that allow for pre-emptive signaling at
the time of disasters
the switch over to a different region
which impacts all of us in terms of sea
routes for distribution of material and
goods as the Panama Canal so if you zoom
in closer we're able to detect through
our imagery over the course of two years
the kind of activity that you can see
this allows the kind of real-time
monitoring that is unprecedented
primarily because of the limited
coverage in open ocean as well as marine
areas
so in summary through a combination of
such real-time environmental sensing as
well as broad area monitoring variable
to extract information that was
previously less available this allows us
to serve transformative applications in
many different vertical industries but
also served that same information for
social good for monitoring disasters
identifying environmental impact and
understanding what's really happening on
the ground at a larger scale most
importantly it allows us to turn our
attention to problems where real-time
sensing and real-time environmental
monitoring can provide real value this
takes us from the realm of Earth
Observation imagery to derive data and
from derive data to descriptive
analytics and spatial temporal insights
that allow us to understand what's
happening in the world so here are a few
resources if you find this interesting
and myself and a couple of colleagues
are here after the session we would love
to talk more if you're interested in
insights from satellite imagery and big
thanks to Google for having us here we
use a significant amount of Google the
storage compute and orchestration
capabilities that Google cloud offers
towards serving up over seven terabytes
of processed imagery every day so with
that thank you very much
Thank You Gopal
and lastly in the interest of time I'll
bring right up our next startup made a
day I they can talk about on the in the
theme of natural disasters how they're
leveraging Google cloud specifically
auto ml to save a lot of lives thank you
so Mayday is an artificial intelligence
base platform and we do natural disaster
information services so since the 80s we
have had one point six trillion damages
one of the most costs this year's
recently was 2017 when it came to
flooding storms and wildfires and even
the red tide 2019 had one of the wettest
went winters on record some of the
biggest natural disasters the cost
economic losses of storms wildfires and
floods about 70% of the u.s. is at risk
from natural disasters we've shifted
from being seasonable and predictable to
be in random and unpredictable the
frequency and severity of these storms
and disasters have made management even
more challenging so a lot of problems
that we come into with disaster
management is outdated platforms they
are decentralized they don't communicate
with each other there's also a lack of
education and training when it comes to
these so with Mayday we've kind of
solved some of these problems we've
created a centralized artificial
intelligence platform that is
cloud-based we have marker services that
track real-time and near real-time
disaster information services from those
events we have localized and group
messaging base to individuals we have a
simple and user-friendly design also we
are highly affordable we are free to
students we have $1.99 for families and
99 cents for individuals alright I'd
like to go ahead and hand it over to
Nitin our CIO Thank You Jacob this is
how made it out AIC ecosystem looks like
we cater to residential commercial and
government enterprise
we our applications runs on web iOS and
Android mobile devices the cool part of
a platform is micro-services in AI
micro-services being an excellent to
integrate and deliver disaster
information services and AI is of a
brainchild with AI we can automate lot
of things which humans are doing we can
detect these disasters through data in
real time
and 24 by 7 and get a quick inside our
data sources we integrate with various
data sources Noah be a part of Noah's
Big Data program using historical data
we train our AI based on the previous
events which have happened we also have
real-time access to geostationary
satellites we get data feeds every 30
seconds for the entire continental US we
use our own propriety algorithms to
detect fire hotspot and other disasters
to augment our capabilities we rely on
visual distractions as well drawn being
part of one of them beasts drones can go
to the areas where human reach is not
easily accessible they can go and do a
reconnaissance operation and give us a
real-time video feeds which we can pass
it through the over AI and detect
actionable events because we are also
trying to use disaster drones for
disaster management and control when the
fire is small it's easy to tackle and
that's where we want to offer drones can
go out and put out the fire when it's
small and contained containable we also
want to integrate various sensors and
equipments which has been installed by
various climatologist and scientific
organizations social media sentiment
analysis in another piece of offering
people who are in who are in the
disaster areas they get the information
firsthand they tweet about it the port
post videos images
and using that social media integration
we want to analyze and bring awareness
and trending of those disasters these
are some of the man-made and natural
disasters which we cater through our
platform we also want to integrate
through IP 911 to bring active shooter
and terrorism activities in real time
this is a brief video which demonstrate
the capability of our platform back in
2018
we detected camp and wolf a fire within
minutes of it's happening as you can see
in this video we have annotations this
yellow boxes being potential fire
hotspot grains one could be false or
non-event and the red are active hotspot
we can also see smoke and cloud and
other geological phenomena which helps
fire firsthand first responders
understand the situation AI being a big
part of our offering this is a
demonstration of Auto ml vision this is
the first part of visual detection we
use satellite imagery and we hand train
this model using this is a short example
being smoke cloud and clear using auto
ml video Auto ml vision we train the
model and after training it's available
as an endpoint using this endpoint we
integrated real time with our live feeds
of images and this short example how it
we can detect smoke cloud with very high
accuracy
another part of our visual offering is
Auto ml video we worked with Google in a
beta program where we use our drone
footage and trained it to detect smoke
fire and other objects in the scene
imagine a drone being going to a place
and give us a real-time video and we
pass it through the streaming API and
generate actionable event you think is
using this this is a third part of our
strategy with this I'll hand it over to
Jacob to talk about our roadmap yep so
in May we are going to launch in eight
cities in Orange County California from
there we are going to create disaster
awareness campaigns for educational
institutes and high occupancy buildings
we'll also be launching later in the air
and all of us in Canada with the IP nine
one integration alright just want to say
thanks to Jason and the rest of the
Google team and also want to thank
Google technical team who I have worked
closely during the beta program they
have been really helpful and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]